wir kommen fragen lotto wir haben uns
fragen speziell für euch ausgedacht
nette diesen grünen und gemeinde die sie
brot die konzerne entscheiden so vielen
ziehen wie ihr wollt ihr könnt alle
ziehen nur die roten beantworten nur die
grünen beantworten dazu würde ich nicht
raten es werden euch alle übel nehmen
und alle danach dessen ihr seid also
einigermaßen ekelhaft ich will ja auch
neben da rauskommen ich kenne ja nicht
euro für kriminelle vergangenheit also
über unsere kriminelle vergangenheit
natürlich nicht vor der kamera
na ja wieder verriet das schon mal
gesagt da die ganzen reparatur ja so als
ob die über ihre ganze geschäft reden
aber dann werden sie ziemlich blöd ihr
habt ein enges verhältnis zu friedberg
schreibt ihr euch schreibt ihr eure text
überhaupt selbst oder macht das fahrrad
für euch natürlich macht uns spaß wir
schreiben unsere texte selber was sonst
das wird uns jetzt schon seit anfang
unserer karriere vorgeworfen auf der
einen seite ist das ein kompliment für
uns weil verrät schreibt mit kollegen
die krassesten texte in deutschland was
punchlines und spitz angeht ich finde
das geil weiß aber dass es wäre ziemlich
blöd warum solche texte uns abgeben wenn
er damit selber viel mehr erreichen
können meist sinnlose ehrlich gesagt
ungern ab weil das ist so eine gedanken
vorgang den kopf vorgeht unter sodann
also für mich ist sie eine punchline
oder jeder fall gleich oder das bild ist
wie ein kleines baby du freust dich dass
du darauf gekommen bist du ganz ehrlich
so würde ich ungern abgeben
ok ich kenne auch journalist muss da
sagt man immer weise modelliert sagt er
danke dass du mir was geschrieben hast
aber ich muss es jetzt schreiben ich
muss es mir mundgerecht man als muss in
meinen mund rhein basel und ein fremder
text kann eigentlich nicht genau die
hand oben abdrehen herzen
mario hat das direkt erkannt nicht so
jasko hat ein großes problem mit dieser
komplizierten aufgabe macht das schon
exakt kommentare die kriegen sie mal auf
der wiesn zu blöd um papier linien zu
öffnen
pilze
macho ist es richtig dass die hersteller
für steroide ohne dich pleite wären okay
ich habe früher habe ich immer
eingekauft bei große lieferanten
steroide und ich hab dann irgendwann so
viel geld ausgegeben dass mir das
finanziell auch nicht mehr leisten
konnte
ich bin zwar unmengen an anabolika und
dann habe ich mir gedacht ich saß dann
eines tages nachts im bett gehabt und
überlegt wie kann ich ein bisschen geld
sparen das geht nicht mehr auf dauer so
weiter dann habe ich in afrika mal
angerufen
in so einem safaripark und die hatten
dann überfluss an büffel herren gehabt
und dann habe ich mir einfach eine
büffelherde nach deutschland liefern
lassen und seitdem produziere ich meine
steroide selbst ich mal auf und ist es
dir vor du beantwortest wie eine schule
wie schafft man es am anfang seiner
karriere
karriere schon zu hdf also hatte es
mittlerweile nichts besonderes
besonderes mehr wird jetzt immer wieder
neue gesichter also aber das war damals
folgendermaßen das war zu deinem video
get your song
red bulls kam da danach raus und dann
hat sich hatte also alkohol vor in dem
fall bei uns gemeldet wir haben zugesagt
kam den duisburg-hamborn hdf gedreht und
ruckzuck also dass wir jetzt
damals war es was besonderes für uns
aber heute wird euro verzichten ehrlich
gesagt ja klar
ach so das ist jetzt nur für die kamera
halt die fresse videos drin also damals
war es interessant wird damals war nur
regional bekannt duisburg so ein
bisschen außerhalb noch jetzt wünscht
man sich mal wieder gründe manchmal
aufgezehrt
was macht euch so unverwechselbar was
macht uns unverwechselbar also das album
ist ein guter grund also wir können wir
bauen selber lachen die machen nicht nur
auffarth und das ist im gegensatz von
andern eigentlich untypisch kein
deutschsprachiger aber ich finde ich bin
gut ich will habe es jetzt eigentlich
nur für die musikalische basis bezogen
wenn wir jetzt über körpermaße reden
dann macht mich persönlich ist
unverwechselbar mein schwanz
du hast angefangen zu trainieren denn
als problem millionen views auf euren
videos was ist ihr erfolgsrezept
also das erfolgsrezept ist
folgendermaßen ich sagte er mario was er
zu tun hat wenn wir das machen würden
was man so will dann wäre das alles im
flop also hier ist der kopf der bande
und deswegen läuft das ganze rund ich
frage mich manchmal ob der erst geworden
jetzt das war jetzt kollegial gewesen
was ich mache ich hab den das mikrofon
abgenommen
wie stabil ist die bizeps aber kommt
direkt aus
aber ich habe gesehen hat schon
angefangen zu zittern mikrofon ist immer
weiter runter gegangen hab ich ja bevor
wir auch noch unheil anrichten und etwas
kaputt machen das mikro jetzt erstmal
weg genommen nicht halt das lieber
selbst schwache witze macht lassen wo
man durchgehen es sei das erste mal bei
clixoom heute deswegen will ich jetzt
nicht sozial sein gegenüber mark immer
gleich machen aber es darf nicht zu
gemeinsam arbeitsmoral mich ein
fremdwort für euch also wir haben spaß
am leben haben spaß am leben wie ihr
unternehmen gerne viel aber im endeffekt
muss man auch sehr hart dafür arbeiten
um am ende die fans überzeugen mit guter
musik und das ist bei uns in fleisch
produkt weil wir haben sehr viele
wortspiele und dafür muss man ordentlich
nachdenken sehr viel zeit opfern damit
auch damit am ende auch ein gutes
produkt bei rumkommt du meinst du lässt
dich einfach gehen und sorgt dafür dass
alles an den start bringen und platzwart
ich picke beats schreib deine texte sagt
dir wenn du zum videodreh kommen soll
sagte er konzerte sind jetzt sagst du
arbeitest sich das immer ganz einfach
der wartet immer bis ich meine guten
statements dann abgeliefert habe und
dann macht er das ganz einfach in denen
er die sachen auf sich bezieht und dass
dann alles verneint
der alte laufende schenkelklopfer
anabolika
privat machen wir das wieder dann noch
erfolgreicher schlägereien dankeschön
passen und möglichst nicht in echt und
st